hi guys i'm lauren zima we are here at
the Woolworth Building where one of the
amazing scenes in fantastic beasts and
where to find them takes place I'm going
to be talking with the cast Eddie
Redmayne everybody about all of the on
set secrets from this new Harry Potter
franchise movie you're interesting man
let's just command just like your
suitcase I think there's much more to
you than meets the eye I mean my
favorite scene is where Newt goes into
the case what is your favorite scene of
the movie oh I love doing that scene
because it was quite a challenge because
they had in the case quite a lot of it
with CGI elements it was talking to lots
of different creatures which quite often
involved talking to nothing so it's like
a very specific challenge but on the
other side of that there's a scene right
at the end which Katherine and I had
he's so smooth it's true we talked about
it because so much of this film was
about imagination and was about
imagining things that weren't there
actually at the end of the film we have
a scene that's just the two of us
chatting and both of us at the end of a
lake
wonder why we're like oh look it was
just two people talking real human
interactive so here to go with the case
full of monsters huh
huge travels first way back when this
all first started I think when you first
signed on for the movie you are not a
parent yet but this is such a movie for
kids are you excited for your daughter
to be able to watch this one day and be
a part of now it will be five films I'm
well I the quick answer is yes only
because I feel like we grew up in some
ways watching those films and getting to
dive into that world and every year or
two and I used to find it so cozy it was
like sort of getting a hug every year or
two from JK Rowling um
and I love the idea of another
generation having something similar and
even though fantastic pieces is it a
different period that's some scary
elements to it so I might be a while
thank you thank you thank you well Eddie
I know that you do a ton of prep work as
an actor but I want to ask you various
artists do you feel you were prepared
for fatherhood is it what you expected I
don't think anything will pave just you
know different parts of your heart
opening and I mean it's it's really
extraordinary what's your favorite part
about it I suppose the weird thing is
that it is the sort of is waking up
every morning probably if she slept
through the night and going in and and
when you go into is lying around and
she's so excited to see another day and
there's nothing untainted or you know so
I hope yet is really damaged it is so
her are very scary film it is to young
age straight to the therapy